we all know we should be eating more
fish but if you're just starting out
cooking it can be really daunting but it
doesn't have to be there's so many great
foolproof ways to cook fish we're going
to show you a few ways to cook fish so
that you can incorporate it into your
diet and never get bored
the first method we're going to show you
is baking fish it's probably the easiest
way to cook fish it's foolproof you can
just do it with salt and pepper but
adding a marinade is just a way to
impart more flavor so it's a little more
exciting so I'm gonna make a really easy
quick marinade with garlic some Prez no
chilies soy sauce and a little balsamic
so you can really get creative with your
marinades the most important thing is to
make sure you have a balance of sweet
salty and acidic but you can use
whatever combination you like I'd
recommend you marinate fish for at least
30 minutes but not over an hour and a
half if you marinate your fish too long
the acid will actually start cooking the
fish and then you're gonna have this
rough rubbery fish no one wants that if
you're short on time you can do it for
five or ten minutes just still get some
of that flavor
once you're done marinating your fish
you want to transfer it to a parchment
paper lined baking sheet bake at 400
degrees for 12 to 14 minutes depending
on how well-done you want your fish cut
12 minutes will be more rare 14 minutes
will be more medium-rare if you go past
16 minutes it'll be a mess
well-done or overcooked fish will be dry
it won't be as tender you're really
missing the point of fish you'll know
when your salmon is cooked through when
you can take a tiny piece off the end
and it flakes off beautifully in the
center is still a warm pink you can add
veggies to your baking sheet and make
your dinner at once baking is great for
a weeknight dinner now that you've
learned how to bake your fish properly
here are two different ways to cook fish
in a pan first up is pan frying this is
a really easy technique that you can use
with any light white fish like tilapia
flounder in our case Sol first you're
going to salt and pepper both sides of
the sole next we're gonna dredge the
fish in flour you just want to make sure
there's a light coating and then shake
off any excess and then we'll move on to
the next step you're gonna heat a pan
over high heat and once you can feel it
getting really hot add a few tablespoons
of butter once the butter starts to
brown it should look golden brown that's
when you add the fish white fish cooks
really fast it should be only a minute
and a half
Perseid when the fish becomes opaque and
the edges start to lift off the pan
that's your sign to flip it and then you
can add lemons for some extra flavor or
you can just leave it as is flour
dredging is great because it protects
the skin from burning and it gives you a
really light crisp crust so that's a
really easy technique for a basic white
fish if you want to get a little fancier
you can use those same techniques with
something like a tuna steak with searing
this is your moment to really splurge on
high quality fish sushi grade fish is
great for Sirian because you'll still
have that rare interior while getting a
beautiful crust so we're gonna keep the
tuna steak super simple first you brush
it with olive oil on all sides then just
sprinkle it with some pepper for Sirian
you're gonna want to use a stainless
steel or a cast iron pan they can handle
higher heat and you're gonna get a
better crust on the bottom preheat the
pan over high heat once it begins to get
really hot you can add the tuna you
don't need to add any more oil since
it's already on the fish for tuna you
want to cook it for about two-and-a-half
minutes per side besides if the fish
should be opaque and the inside should
be pink
once the sides are completely opaque
remove it from the heat and let it rest
for five to ten minutes
Syrian is great for deeply colored oily
flavorful high-quality fish you can
really let the flavor of the fish stand
out with Syrian pan-fried enterin is a
bit more advanced but it's a great way
to get more of a variety of texture and
great flavor out of your fish next up
poaching poaching fish gets a bad rep
for being super boring but it doesn't
have to be here's an easy way to make a
really flavorful poached fish the joy of
poaching is that it's super easy you
fill a pot with water and then you can
add basically whatever you want we're
gonna add leeks dill lemon juice and
salt
you could add other alliums you could
add spices it's really up to you the
important thing is just make sure you
have some kind of acid in salt once
you've got all that in your pot then add
the fish then we're gonna turn the heat
on poaching is great for fish that are
really flavorful on their own like
salmon arctic char and halibut for a
deep poach you generally want to bring
the heat up between 140 degrees to 180
degrees
we're gonna poach it 160 degrees which
is a good middle point once the water is
at 160 degrees that's when you set your
timer we're gonna set it for about 12
minutes or until the fish turns opaque
this depends on the size of your fish so
just make sure to keep an eye on it you
want to make sure the temperature
doesn't get too
otherwise the fish could break apart and
you're going to have a really rough
overcooked texture the joy of poaching
is that you can do it with water you can
do with wine or you can even do it with
olive oil
poaching doesn't have to be boring and
it's really easy it's another great
weeknight option so now that you've
learned a healthy way to cook fish we're
gonna talk about an unhealthy one frying
fry is great but it's probably not
something you want to do by yourself on
a weeknight it's more labor-intensive
and it's more messy than the other
techniques we went over but it's really
delicious and it's really fun if you
have a big group of people over we're
gonna show you an easy recipe for how to
make your battered Cod so first I'm
gonna cut the fish into 2-inch pieces
once we're done with that we can move on
to the batter when frying fish you want
to use a mild white fish like cod
catfish or flounder mild fish is ideal
because the frying imparts a ton of
flavor for this batter I'm gonna use
flour old bay chili powder garlic powder
salt and pepper you whisk it together
add a beaten egg and then add a beer of
your choice this is a fairly standard
recipe for your battered fish but you
can really play around with other spices
that you like you want to make sure the
batter isn't too wet and loose you also
want to make sure that there are no
lumps it should be slightly thick and
smooth so next we're gonna dip the cut
pieces of fish into the batter we're
gonna make sure they're evenly coated on
all sides once you're done with that
it's time to fry when you're frying you
want to make sure to use a neutral oil
like canola vegetable or peanut oil
because it doesn't impart any other
flavors onto the fish we're going to fry
these at 350 degrees for two to three
minutes or until it becomes golden brown
make sure you do this in batches so you
don't overcrowd the pot otherwise it'll
bring the temperature down and the fish
won't cook properly
once you're done fry and transfer it to
a wire rack so that all the grease can
drip off while the fish is still hot
make sure to give it a good sprinkle
salt so that it really sets in let's be
real who doesn't love fried fish it's
something you'd want to do for parties
if you're trying to show off for even
more tips on frying check out our other
video on how to fry everything cooking
fish can seem intimidating but as you
can see it doesn't have to be it's
actually pretty simple now that you know
these five techniques give them a spin
and see which one's your favorite get
the flavor however you want honey
[Laughter]
by it's been a long day
[Music]
[Music]